waiting outside an immigration office in
mexico city these haitian migrants have
decided it's safer to ask to stay here
rather than risk crossing the u.s border
i am hearing people are being deported
to haiti and right now haiti is very bad
they don't have a president there are
many things so we can't go there that's
why i'm afraid and i want to live here
in mexico
in recent days the u.s has been sending
more migrants back home following the
arrival of thousands of haitian
nationals on the u.s mexico border but
not all are being repatriated many who
have crossed into the state of texas
have been given paperwork and a date to
appear in u.s immigration court
though there's confusion about how
authorities decide who goes and who
stays right now it's not clear how they
are being processed what criteria border
patrol is using
to say who
should have access to parole who's going
on the deportation flights
this week images of u.s border patrol
agents on horseback mistreating haitian
migrants provoked international outrage
agents captured on video by al jazeera
have been placed under investigation
human rights observers warn that
conditions for migrants on the mexican
side of the border are even more
challenging and immigration agents here
in mexico have also been accused of
abusing migrants
more haitian migrants are expected to
arrive in mexico's capital in the days
and weeks ahead
there's much
many are going to abandon the north and
come down here to the city in search of
new opportunities so i think that
migration will continue to increase and
we as authorities must do something to
provide the solution that the case
requires
elsewhere in northern mexico people are
rounded up in immigration raids and sent
south towards the border with guatemala
where more migrants from haiti and
elsewhere in latin america arrive daily
and these last months the number of
haitian people arriving in mexico has
increased drastically this is
interesting because haitians are not
arriving directly from haiti instead
many are traveling from as far away as
brazil and chile
international observers warned that mass
deportations could overwhelm haiti as
thousands returned to the same cycle of
violence poverty and political
instability that forced them to leave in
the first place manuel rapalo al jazeera
mexico city